it was like I was vibrating at this
weird frequency all the time hey I get
it but then I found this forum for Trans
kids and it was like that's who I am but
if you want to see what else uh Netflix
is doing as you know it's not just
making your kids think that they're
racist and you feeling guilty about your
whiteness and oppressiveness and all
that stuff uh they are also trying to
chop your children's genitals off here's
a show called big mouth on
Netflix gay yeah I did kind of think you
were gay so did I but then I sang this
duet with the ghost of Mercury sure as
one does gay totally gay and I realized
that didn't feel right either it was
something more than that what's your
problem kid I don't know I just know I
hate you and what you're doing to my
body nobody likes puberty that's why
they made the show it was like I was
vibrating at this weird frequency all
the time hey I get it but then I found
this for for Trans kids and it was like
that's who I am so I told my parents oh
God did they freak out sort of yeah but
then my mom started listening to Lady
Gaga and sadly that's what made her come
around don't love but go on I like that
movie where boyfriend pisses pants at
the gramys so we decided I should go on
hormone blockers all right let's get you
some tow
hair you I was going to make you such a
man you were going to have dry knees and
the confidence to wear flip-flops with
long nails and now you'll never write
for
billb and now I'm here and the boys are
dicks and the girls are also dicks but
like in a more decimating way yes what
is up with that guys look anyone can
make whatever art they want and you have
to decide if you want to pay for it and
you have to decide what you want to put
your kids in front of and see how that
infects them um I don't think there's a
problem with being gay my husband's gay
I'm gay after 10 p.m. okay it's fine
it's just fine it's not something they
have to scream about or make a big deal
about really something I usually just do
in my own home um
but but these people push and then I
went on hormone blockers and I listened
to Lady Gaga and I chopped my wang off
and I it's just absolutely insane but
you know this is being pushed it's being
pushed
relentlessly uh here's a compilation of
Disney shows going full woke too the
flag stands for us as a group of people
being united and being with each other
in a time of need this country was built
on slavery which means slaves built this
country the flag means everything to me
it means life it means freedom it also
means unity and it means love we the
descendant of slaves in America have
earned reparations for their suffering
and continue to earn reparations every
moment we spend submerged in the
systemic Prejudice racism and white
supremacy all the flags you know you
ride down the street and it makes you
feel connected like we're in this
together we celebrate juneth for theth
time our account is still outstanding
cuz this country was built on slavery
which means built this country what
happened to Disney why was Disney then
like that and now like this why did
Disney chop its own genitals off and the
reason I'm showing you that I know we've
shown you that clip before is because if
they can do that to kids and if they've
been doing that to kids for years
thinking that America is evil and
founded on slavery and if you're a boy
you're actually a girl and all of that
stuff if they can do that to your kids
at 5 years old and 7 years old and 9
years old and then you send them to
Harvard where they can chant for
genocide and call the bad guys good and
the good guys bad and then they can get
those kids out of those universities
into all of our uh institutions do you
think our institutions might crumble
over time you know
it